vous avez été ministre de la culture le
csa a mis en demeure la chaîne
d'information i télé alors que la
rédaction est toujours en grève pour
manquements donne était de rigueur
elle s'en prend directement la direction
de cette chaîne vous soyez ministre au
corps de la culture aujourd'hui vous
feriez quoi pour cette chaîne a écouté
je pense que on voit bien que les les
chartes éthiques et tous les engagements
qui sont pris par les patrons de chaînes
sont parfois des lettres mortes
moi je pense qu'il faut renforcer c'est
ce que j'avais essayé de faire en tant
que ministre c'est extrêmement difficile
je dois le dire l'indépendance des
rédactions il faut donner une véritable
indépendance le départ il tente
aujourd'hui cette rédaction pour leur
donner la force de pouvoir résister à
leurs actionnaires
c'est ça aujourd'hui l'enjeu donc
premièrement renforcer l'indépendance
des rédactions et 2 je veux dire
l'indépendance juridique permettre aux
sociétés de journalistes d'être
véritablement des personnes
juridiquement autonome de leurs
actionnaires et deuxièmement ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut qu'on s'attaque
enfin ce qu'on n'a pas pu faire pendant
ce quinquennat mais à la concentration
de la propriété d'un certain nombre de
grands groupes de presse
elle vaut qu'on voit passer directement
au patron mais aujourd'hui dépassé 100
bolloré pas seulement bolloré mais on
voit aujourd'hui qu'il y a quatre ou
cinq personnes extrêmement riche en
france qui détiennent des chaînes de
télévision oui des chaînes de télévision
des journaux et qu'il ya des empires de
presse écrite et audiovisuelle qui se
sont créés et qu'ils ne sont pas
indépendants et du pouvoir exaucer de
quoi sur la d re nation abbas est une
grande menace sur l'information
c'est une grande menace sur la liberté
démocratique ici on a de la chance parce
qu'on est sur une chaîne indépendante
parce qu'elle est totalement totalement
public et heureusement et donc quand
vous prenez la chaîne comme il est parié
qu'aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
indépendante
on en finira sur sa carrière en tout cas
je considère les journalistes font
preuve d'une qu'un grand courage d'une
grande indépendance je les salue et je
les soutiens
parce qu'en plus ils sont évidemment
menacé de représailles dans leur
carrière doivent pas lâcher ils ne
doivent pas lâcher et continuer la
grande et heureusement que cs a enfin
pris cette décision mais maintenant il
ya un problème c'est comment on fait
pour que l'on ne puisse pas avoir ainsi
d empire audiovisuel et de presse écrite
qui se constituent dans les mains de
licences qui sont des puissances
économiques